warning the following video contains
spoilers it's a freaking reaction video
what do you expect hey listen shut up
navi so our heroes make it to the top of
the tree and what there's no floating
city the developers lied about the grand
quest those evil bastards are the
reunion of the sweetest mom dad and
daughter ever how old are they again
well how the [ __ ] can i take this
seriously well now that they're together
there's nothing that could possibly go
wrong joey didn't see this one coming uh
admiral akbar do you want to take this
one it's a trap and here comes the main
villain as usual looking about as
threatening as the fashionable butterfly
and now i shall proceed to tell my evil
plan to the main character because that
has always worked out well
what's this you're having a party hell
yeah oh [ __ ] is that kind of party oh
brilliant more rape just what my boner
ordered wait wait you're telling me
there's a pain system in the game that
could possibly affect your real world
body how the [ __ ] did this game make it
to mass market yes boner up oh boner
epic rape music
not sure if he's kissing her or trying
to lick her face off oh hi season one
villain the [ __ ] are you doing here get
up neo you are the one you can do it as
long as you believe in the heart of the
cards remember the bonds of friendship
the power of love will find a way okay
i'm out of cliche lines now what the
[ __ ] is going on none of this makes any
logical sense hey sword art online how's
your anus feeling cause that was a
pretty big [ __ ] massive sword tiny
sword insert dick choke here yes that's
right glorify the man who trapped
thousands of people in a game causing
hundreds to die i can't remember why he
was a bad guy either
okay
let me hear that one more time okay
one more time
yes
yes this is the most epic jewel of all
time beats the [ __ ] out of the season
one finale well there goes his right
hand we all know what he won't be doing
now
wanking and so comes the end to the best
villain of all time let us take a second
to remember all the great moments he's
given us
blah blah romance oh [ __ ]
so are you ever going to tell us why you
wanted to trap thousands of people in a
game no well thanks anyway old buddy old
pal hey look it's plot wait um we're
forgetting something
shut up navi since i'm such a
responsible father i'm gonna [ __ ] off
now to the real world and leave you here
by yourself oh
so what were you just doing to my body
just now oh so you're happy he can see
asana now it's not like you were just
crying about it literally two episodes
ago or anything i can't wait to review
this
[Music]